The next type of analysis
we'll discuss is aggregation.
This method simply means calculating
a value across a group or
dimension and
is commonly used in data analysis.
For example,
you may want to aggregate sales data for
a sales person by month, adding all
the sales closed for each month.
Then, you may want to
aggregate across dimensions,
such as sales by month
per sales territory.
In this scenario, you could calculate
the sales per month for each sales
person, and then add the sales per month
for all salespeople in the region.
Aggregation is often done in
reporting to be able to slice and
dice information, to help managers
make decision and view performance.
For example, you may start with the
total sales per year during an analysis.
You can refine this to sales per
quarter, then later specify a region or
a particular sales person.